but first year breaking overnight
Southern California braces for more
aftershocks after another powerful
earthquake rocks the area the magnitude
7.1 quake was felt from Los Angeles all
the way to Nevada the latest earthquake
happened just after 8:00 p.m. local time
ceiling lights to sway at this casino in
California about 90 miles east of Los
Angeles the quake also caused injuries
sparked fires and closed roadways and
this roller coaster on the Las Vegas
Strip could be seen swing from the shock
waves as passengers on board made their
way to the top of a 180 foot mansion
being on that as the earthquake is going
on
yeah the quake was centered in the
Mojave Desert in the town of Ridgecrest
which is still recovering from a 6.4
quake on the 4th of July Carter Evans
begins our coverage in rich crest Carter
I know you've been there since the very
beginning what are you feeling and what
are you seeing right now well we've been
feeling a lot of shaking and we're
seeing a lot of damage this is what it
looks like in the East Ridge market the
violent quake littered the aisles take a
look on the other side over here you can
see all these wine bottles strewn all
over the floor it seems like this that
are playing out throughout the region a
lot of wine came down you could see it's
all broken bottles and we could just
keep going all over the store it's
everywhere convenience store owner tony
abdul latif had just finished cleaning
up from the last quake when his store
and ridge crest was thrown into chaos
yet again by a violent earthquake his
security video stops when the power went
out I would say it's like three four
times lost than yesterday so that much
more that much more we definitely have
an earthquake going on
the quake struck at 8:19 last night it
rattled Dodger Stadium while the home
team took on the San Diego Padres our
colleagues at KCBS were caught off guard
once again by the shaking only this time
they were live on the air last night 7.1
magnitude earthquake could be felt
across the state I've been here for
years this is the worst from Northern
California to the Thomas and Mack Center
in Las Vegas where an NBA Summer League
game was postponed officials in
California are reporting injuries some
structural damage and road closures as a
result of the quake having a pretty
difficult time tonight seismologist Lucy
Jones says there have been more than a
thousand smaller quakes since his 6.4
bagnat oude earthquake rattled the same
region on Independence Day that shaker
is now considered a for shock to the
much larger quake last night now the
largest to shake the region in two
decades well so far there are no reports
of serious injuries or deaths the
governor has declared a state of
emergency and search and rescue teams
they're going through the city they're
looking for anyone who might have been
injured or trapped the damage
assessments are going to be pouring in
throughout the day and you know what
we're also going to be feeling those
aftershocks the seismologists say there
is a very good chance we could feel
aftershocks in the range of a magnitude
5 or even a magnitude 6 and they say
there is a 1 in 20 chance that we'll
have a bigger earthquake than the one we
had last night Dana all right Carter
thank you so much people they're
obviously bracing themselves for more it
really is amazing when you think about
everybody thought that 6.4 was was the
big one in this and now it turns out
that was the four shot that was the four
shock right and again it's Carter
mentions there was a chance here
probabilities change depending on who
you talk to a little bit but 10 to 20
percent chance or 5 to 10 percent chance
of of another earthquake being bigger
than a seven point one right and if
you're in Ridgecrest you don't care what
the chances are you just want to break
right now that's right it does so much
damage in such a short amount of time
and as they say long-term the chances of
the big one happening are 100 percent so